uh it's lunch money time ladies and
gentlemen
today's lunch money is brought to you by
ftx ftx they've got some of the lowest
fees in the entire industry usually
they're about 85 percent lower fees than
many of their competitors on top of that
ftx also not only has incredible
liquidity and great pricing they are
in beta have the stocks
that they're going to bring to the
market and the reason why they're so
interesting is when they bring those
stocks
you are going to be able to buy stocks
with no transaction fees zero
transaction fees and they will also not
conduct payment for order flow meaning
that they're not gonna take your trades
and go send them to hedge funds to then
front run you ftx trying to bring
together bitcoin cryptocurrencies
digital stocks all into one place and
just keep focusing on innovation and
getting the cost to actually go and
purchase these assets as low as possible
ftx is also just cool-ass brand they got
the arena in miami i'm a big fan i think
they're absolutely pushing the pace of
innovation let's go check them out you
can click on the link in the description
plana how are you good to see you oh
wait that's not me oh my god oh i was
that was a magic trick that was a magic
are you a ghost oh don't start with the
ghost for a second i thought i was a
ghost don't start with the ghost [ __ ]
well wait can i tell a quick story about
the ghost yes okay so uh one of my
friends i'll not say who she is but she
basically was like oh my god i
forgot i left the shower on and i went
on a walk with my husband and then he
was like
they came back and he was like did you
leave the shower on and she was like i
was like oh my god i'm so sorry i don't
know what i was thinking and i was like
let me teach you a one sentence solution
to such a problem
anytime that happens to me i say oh my
god we must have a ghost and he accepts
it and then we move on
what
it's true
i'm ready to start okay
all right
so i don't [ __ ] with you i'm not a ghost
um so
senator kristen gillibrand who's a
democrat and uh cynthia loomis who's a
or is it lummus who's a republican uh
have been collaborating on a bill that
would kind of
propose some crypto regulation so people
know what the rules of the road are and
their offices touted this bill as
landmark bipartisan legislation that
will create a complete regulatory
framework for digital assets that
encourages responsible financial
innovation flexibility transparency and
robust consumer protections while
integrating digital assets into existing
law so this is important right because
until now it's kind of been like a dark
box of like what are we doing we want to
innovate we don't want to
we don't want to piss anybody off the
single most important word in all of
this is bipartisan
if there's one thing
in our polarized world that brings
together republicans and democrats it's
bitcoin and the reason is because
bitcoin is the embodiment of every
single one of the american ethos
democracy
capitalism
freedom of speech
the right to private property the right
to be able to protect your private
property
all of that is embodied in bitcoin and
so naturally seeing them say hey we need
regulatory clarity
that makes a lot of sense to me
and to have them come together on both
sides of the aisle that makes a lot of
sense to me and the fact that they are
saying
that they will
put it under the cftc
makes a lot of sense to me
one of the problems that we have in
america in my personal opinion is that
we don't teach financial education in
school
why don't we teach financial education
in school
a big part of it is because the people
who are teaching in school don't know
[ __ ] about money
the teachers they don't know anything
how are they supposed to teach it they
don't know
most people's parents they weren't
successful financially so how are they
supposed to teach it so of course if the
two people who teach you the most in
life weren't good at something it's hard
for them to teach it so a second piece
of it would be why don't we send people
into the schools who are good at
teaching this stuff so that they then
can share that information
well it's because the government just
steps and says don't worry we'll protect
you we'll make sure that you can't
invest in anything that could possibly
have risk associated with it and that's
where all this regulation comes in but
at the end of the day what i know is
that in the united states we have taken
the idea of the rich get richer and
written it into law it's called
accreditation loss
the private market
which has captured a
lion's share of returns over the last
decade
if you do not make more than 200 000 a
year you cannot invest in the private
market
if you do not have a household net worth
of over a million dollars you cannot
invest in the private market the
accreditation laws prevent people from
investing you can go buy lottery tickets
you can go to the casino but god forbid
if you had a chance to invest in uber or
facebook or airbnb or stripe or anything
else why is gambling legal why is vegas
around
it's because i remember money online
remember during the pandemic
yes do you remember
alcohol sales okay but that was a deal
they were still rolling
you could go buy lottery tickets
if the government can get revenue they
keep those those things open
all of a sudden they were saying hey
essentials let's keep them open why
because they tax the [ __ ] out of those
things
the lottery
is literally a tax on stupid people in
america well sometimes it you know like
no and then they say we're gonna take
the money and fund our uh yeah we're
gonna fund our schools imagine that well
i think that's good
you think it's good yeah
i think that what they should do is they
should say to people i went to school on
the hope scholarship in georgia for all
those who know it's funded by the
lottery
i think that what they should do is they
should not have the government
encouraging people to gamble
i don't care if they're getting tax
revenue or not if the private market
wants to do it fine but why should the
government be allowed to do it i don't
know why are there states where online
gambling or sports gambling is illegal
but the government can have lotteries
i don't know well i know exactly why
it's because the government's making
money go ahead next
yeah i wish we could solve this today
but we can't
okay
i don't think we're gonna solve anything
today ah so where are we even here
recession
recession oh yeah recession so the ceo
of servicenow which is like software
company i just looked it up says that
current economic downturn is not even
close to 2008 crisis he said this is not
even close to 2008 in 2008 i was with a
company where we lost a billion euros on
pipeline in a day that was a crisis
he says that if anything this is a
crisis of opportunity i don't know about
this well i agree and i disagree i don't
think that it's anywhere near the 2008
crisis
well yes he doesn't know yeah he can
look at the data and see that it's
nowhere near what right now but it could
be it could get worse so that unknown so
far but as of the moment it's not i
disagree that it's a crisis of
opportunity that's a little bit of a
stretch uh it feels like people who have
liquidity strong balance sheet etc they
may be able to capitalize but i don't
know if you can call it a crisis of
opportunity there's a lot of people that
are uh suffering at the moment and the
the worst part about this entire thing
is since the beginning of this pandemic
uh which by the way has been over for a
very long time uh in certain states uh
they
being the central banks and the
politicians created undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy and they
punished the bottom 45 of americans when
asset prices exploded upwards if you're
in the bottom 45 percent you had no
investment assets you did not
participate in the upswing at all you
just got hit with high inflation
now as they are crashing the asset
prices and they are pushing us closer
and closer to economic contraction and
potentially a recession
the same 45 of the people on the bottom
they're getting hurt again and so it
doesn't matter good time bad time they
just keep getting hurt it's not good but
i don't know if i would agree that uh
this is a crisis of opportunity yeah
because it's kind of like we just had a
reversion to the me he he basically said
that it's a crisis opportunity because
the digital transformation market is 11
trillion dollars in the next few years
if you're going to fight inflation
you're going to keep your employees
inspired no matter where they work from
sounds like he's talking this book i'm
sure he's a nice guy i i don't buy it
all right what's up with child care
child care so i was thinking about this
there really hasn't been a ton of
innovation in child care since like
care.com like i can't think of another
platform that's as popular
you're finding what do you want virtual
diapers
what virtual diapers those won't work
there's just like one company it's like
a monopoly i'm not even sure it's not
good so
finding and affording child care is one
of the biggest challenges that parents
face so now there's this company called
kinside that makes the process easier by
not only providing a marketplace
verified carers but they also help
parents tap into like flexible spending
accounts and other benefits to afford
the care they're raising 12 million
dollars in series a funding
from mothers like the round was led by
mothers so they're they include sasha
sasha mckenzie of wellington ventures
joanna drake of magnify ventures
initialized aldo lou dennis and maeve
inventor sarah this one i think that's
cool big problem obviously problem oh i
think that um
child care you mean not yeah i mean i
actually i actually have a very
interesting thought about child care
what do you have uh some people may
disagree with me on this but but i think
that one of the great luxuries of life
is as somebody becomes uh
more financially secure they have time
to spend with their kids some people
choose not to do it but it becomes
something that is uh much more
obvious or
available
and so in some ways
these companies what they're really
trying to do is they're trying to help
uh parents who are trying to juggle a
lot of different things right like i
think a lot about uh
there's people that you and i know uh
they're single mothers they may have
one job that's very grueling maybe
sometimes two uh i'm sure that we know
people who have you know two jobs plus a
side hustle whatever and they're trying
to take care of their kid yeah and
it's just like
they are super human i know i i i don't
understand how they do it i can't uh
and unfortunately if that's the
situation you're in usually you may not
have the financial means to go and hire
somebody like this and so it ends up
being this like very interesting balance
of like how do you solve the problem for
the people who need it most uh but also
be able to build a business that is
sustainable that can last for a long
time so you can service you know
millions and millions of people who need
help that's why i think on the surface
it looks like this company is
interesting because not only do you find
the caregiver but they also help you pay
and afford that character it's like a
financing component yeah oh okay yeah
look at that i didn't even know that
they helped them tap into fsas and other
benefits to got it got it got it okay
all right next all right uh so this is
interesting 73 of affluent investors in
asia intend to hold some form of digital
assets by the end of 2022 according to a
new report by accenture why are you
laughing accenture is doing these
reports
you said 73 yeah i didn't realize that
27 of affluent people in asia are stupid
why
if you're a wealthy person
and you don't have exposure at this
point to digital assets of any kind
whether it's stable coins bitcoin
something else whatever you got to start
to ask yourself like
where you been well it's hard to ask
that when we're not talking about the
market is down
no
it it it's like saying uh oh zoom is
down 90 from the peak is it really
google it yeah i think it's dude zoom
stock yeah i think it's done 90 or
something like that from the peak
and so it's at 114 go no go back up here
yep click uh click five year five year
yeah what was it at before
where
what what was that number right there
492 559. so it's at 559 and it's at what
114 dollars so it's down like 80 yeah
but that was also 20 20 when again i'm
just saying down 80 percent yeah yeah
yeah and and so what ends up happening
is over that same time period pretty
pandemic to now bitcoins up 300 percent
right bitcoin is outperformed stocks
bonds currencies commodities whatever
i'm not saying you got to go and put all
of your money in but i'm saying at this
point there's questions that you have to
ask somebody who is sophisticated who
has the financial means who does not
have uh exposure well despite the rising
interest among asia's investors most
most wealth management firms in the
region do not yet offer clients a
digital asset proposition so that could
be so yeah and if you're listening to
your wealth advisor yeah
uh i i think that that's one thing is
that if you go to if you only operate
through it but it goes back to the same
ideas like you're responsible for your
own wealth if you are relying on
somebody else uh that is not going to
work out very well for you
right all right what's next all right so
there's this lady in california who was
scrolling through craigslist and she
found two sofas and a matching chair
that somebody was giving away for free
and so then
she made the startling discovery to find
more than 36 thousand dollars in cash
hidden inside one of the cushions
awesome that's a lot of coins what
what you do with this you keep it or
give it back
well she said i just moved in i don't
have anything in my house i was so
excited so we picked it up and brought
it in oh wait this is about before she
found the money sorry all right okay and
then she thought it was a heat pad but
it wasn't the heat pad and then she told
her son to like come over here this is
money she tried to call the guy
and then
oh she said she was never tempted to
keep what she found she said she
immediately gave the money back to the
family who gave her the french good
person wow
she said god has been kind to me and my
children they're all alive and well have
three beautiful grandchildren so what
can i ever ask from god that's so nice
what what always uh impresses me about
these stories yeah is
a woman who's on craigslist getting free
furniture right is the one who is giving
i know gives the money back i know right
it's just good people maybe well so as a
way of saying thank you the family
agreed to give her twenty two hundred
dollars money she needed to buy a new
refrigerator and she said i was not
expecting a dime from him i was not can
i that's awesome
how do i find this woman
i'm going to find this woman all right i
don't want to be involved
i do like that the family gave her i do
too but come on like a finder's fee
honestly if i just give her all all of
it she she gave it to her well she found
it it's 36 thousand dollars why was it
in their cushion that is a question that
i don't want the answer to
all right well if somebody can help you
find this lady also uh it's not like you
left some coins what is her name like
coins are one thing but vicky a packet
of cash it's pretty aggressive what a
great 36 thousand dollars all right
anything else you got for us um no that
is all i have does anybody else have
anything for me
uh people are asking in the chat about
uh see i take live ask
lunch money uh people are asking me in
the chat about uh quitting their jobs
about why
uh
they're saying like hey should you quit
your job and then go try to find a new
one or should you find the new one then
quit your job
and uh the short answer is like every
situation is different yeah uh as one
person described if you have a job that
is affecting your mental health then
yeah maybe you need to scoot on out of
there uh scoop but one of the key things
is it ideally you can find a new job
before you quit your old job uh right
now there's about 11 million open jobs
in america if you don't like your job
you probably can find another one
uh and if you have not gotten a pay
raise
in uh the last two years uh you are
unlikely to be being paid more than you
were then you're probably getting paid
less
that your dad gave you it was like if
you're at a company for more than oh my
dad one time told me he said uh
many people work at a place for 10 years
and some people uh get 10 years of
experience but many people get two years
of experience five times it's so true
right and if you think about it like if
you if you basically have been take if
you've been somewhere for four years and
you got 90 of the value of what you
learned etc uh in the first two years
and now you're just basically doing the
same thing over and over and over again
you're not growing you're not you know
learning more then if you stay there for
a decade like yeah you just got two
years of experience five times uh and so
uh it can be uh very beneficial uh to
say hey look i wanna grow i wanna go do
something but i also think that there's
a huge piece of this being
it's on you like that's another thing
that a lot of people i think forget is
that you can work at a company and you
know i always say one get paid obviously
your salary but either try to get equity
or try to get some sort of upside uh in
the performance of the business
then what you want to be able to do is
you want to be able to make sure that
you're constantly learning but a lot of
people go to work and they're like man i
don't learn nothing here i don't learn
nothing you know nothing here that's me
okay and then i always say to them like
what are you doing to learn
what are you doing yeah
why are you not going and seeking new
information
why are you not doing this and the truth
is i think what a lot of people have
realized is when you go to work if
people are really honest with themselves
right it's kind of like school planning
and i were talking the other day about
school
if you send your kid to school how much
time do they actually spend learning so
let's say the kids school starts at
eight o'clock and they get out at three
that's seven hours right if my math is
uh is correct there and so they're at
school for seven hours but they probably
do like three hours of learning
you have home room you've got uh lunch
you've got recess you've got the time
between classes you've got the actual
time to get into the classroom sit down
calm everyone down
yeah then okay let's start packing up
our stuff before like when you actually
add it all up my guess is about half of
the time it's about three and a half
hours or so of learning out of the seven
hours and for you it was probably even
less than that
i got a
i got what i would consider a hallway
education i don't want to know about
those street pants in the hallway
that's literally what i got was i got a
hallway education
a hallway education has three pillars to
it if i had to describe it
the first pillar of a hallway education
is that you constantly are trying to
figure out how to get out of the
classroom into the hallway okay so
that requires sales marketing recruiting
that requires a lot of complex thinking
critical skills uh requires problem
solving et cetera he's making this [ __ ]
up how to get out of the classroom into
the hallway that's the pillar one of
hallway education the second thing is
that you spend as much time in the
hallway before you have to go into the
next class
so what does that require usually that
it requires oh [ __ ] i didn't do the
homework yo yo yo did you do the
homework hey come over here real quick
let me just quickly you know let's work
together on this [ __ ] okay
so collaboration collaboration skills
teamwork you know problem solving
critical thinking persuasion on all of
that part of the hallway education
and then the third thing
that happens
is that there are things that happen in
the hallway
that you try to
participate in
without getting in trouble or stopped by
the principal in the hallway
are you selling candy and those things
well there's business that happens in
the hallway
a lot a lot of businesses going on
there's also pranks that happen little
team building exercise
there's also the avoidance of the
principle you know a little uh ability
to kind of dart around and everything
i'm just saying i got a hallway
education
it's fast as many times as possible get
out of the classroom into the hallway
spend as much time in the hallway and do
cool [ __ ] in the hallway hallway
education over classroom education
all day every day
i love all of you i appreciate you guys
i'm just here to drop knowledge bye
see ya